Speaker 1: Texas Republican Senator Ted Cruz
has now eliminated any doubt whatsoever that
remained that, yes, he is a completely disgusting
and immoral human being. We are going to look at
a couple of examples here in the first couple
of segments of the show at the hypocritical and
disgusting reactions from multiple Republicans
to the latest news that Mike Pence also had
classified documents at his home. Now, later in
the program and maybe tomorrow even, we're going
to look at the rise of immediate conspiracy
theories surrounding the classified documents
story involving Joe Biden and Mike Pence. But
for now, let's look at the pretzels that some
of these Republicans are twisting themselves into
and sometimes very brazenly. Ted Cruz appeared on
television with Larry Kudlow. Larry Kudlow, I
guess after working for Trump, he got a show
back now on Fox Business. And as you can see, if
you if you're watching, Kudlow just looks like he
really enjoys himself when he hosts these shows,
doesn't he? And Ted Cruz started talking about,
oh, well, the FBI needs to investigate not only
Joe Biden but Hunter Biden because of everything
that's going on. And Larry Kudlow, to his credit,
plays a sort of soft devil's advocate and says,
well, I don't know. I mean, you know, Pence
also had documents there. And Ted Cruz, I don't
know. Don't worry about that. We know where those
documents came from. Do we? Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Then this shifts from a
political problem to a very serious
problem of criminal liability and major crimes.
And so Neil needs to search the University of
Delaware archives and they need to search
Hunter Biden's home and business address.
Speaker 3: Just as an addendum to this. The
news came out today, I'm sure you saw it,
that former Vice President Mike Pence, a friend of
both bars, he's found some classified documents.
Speaker 1: It turns out that a friend
of both of ours is a big factor here.
Speaker 3: I think, at his home in Indiana,
not in his office. What do you make of that?
Is this different from the Biden story?
Speaker 1: Does this just like I know this
is totally meaningless, Senator, but like, just
so I can say I put the question on the record,
There's no similarity, is there?
Speaker 3: Complicate the story. We're going
to continue the bull market and special counsels.
I'd rather have a bull market in stocks than in
special counsels. How do you see it, Senator Cruz?
Speaker 2: Oh, look, the Mike Pence story,
it's still early on. You know, Mike Pence
and as you noted, he is a good friend. He's
a good man. He's explained where these came
from. What right has put out is is that in
packing up the vice presidential offices, that
that there were a couple of papers that were
classified that were inadvertently a.
Speaker 1: Couple inadvertently but.
Speaker 2: Non-classified materials
that was a mistake. But there's no
reason to think it was anything but inadvertent.
Speaker 1: There is no reason to think that the
Biden stuff was anything but inadvertent. Listen,
it's not partizan for me. It's not even partizan
as some of our our friends across the pond like to
say. There are right now three situations we know
about Trump, Biden and Pence. I have no reason
to believe that the Biden one is anything but
inadvertent. If the facts change, I will revise
my opinion. I have no reason to think that the
Pence situation is anything but inadvertent. The
facts change. I will revise my opinion. I have
every reason to think that the Trump situation
is deliberate. Given the dozens of different data
points and reports about Trump directed people
to do this. Once the FBI and National Archives
became interested in the documents, they're on
video moving the documents around rather than
simply packing them up to be turned back over to
the National Archives. The fact that Trump pushed
his lawyers to lie and say, We gave you back what
we have, even though Trump knew that they hadn't,
it's piece of evidence upon piece of evidence.
These are three situations. Two seem benign,
one seems deliberately criminal.
Speaker 2: That is very different from
what Joe Biden has done. Joe Biden has given
zero explanation as to how these classified
documents got there. And in particular,
he has given no explanation as to how he
has documents from his time in the Senate list.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So as as many of you, of course,
know, the Republican Party and people like Ted
Cruz are numb to hypocrisy. It's astonishing
hypocrisy. It's mind blowing. And they are
completely numb or immune to it. There is no
political punishment for it. In fact, often they
are rewarded for maintaining the party line the
way that Ted Cruz is doing. And at the end of
the day, what the hell do you expect from a guy
who had his wife called ugly by Donald Trump and
then turned around and supported Trump and talked
about how great, how great Trump is. Now, there is
another side to this. Okay, maybe we see it as hip
hop. Or C, but they don't. What I mean by that is
they might see it as we aren't hypocrites. We are
good and Democrats are bad. We deserve power.
Democrats don't. We are above reproach even for
the same things that we criticize Democrats for
doing. And that's it, right? It could be a means
justify the end sort of thing, and that they
fundamentally deserve different treatment and
different considerations, even for the same things
when applied to Democrats. That's a possibility.
The other is they're just hypocrites and brazenly
so. And why would they stop being hypocrites given
that they are never punished for it? So that's
Ted Cruz. Let's now go to another example of this.